welcome to the 7d coach an episode 200
Street meet this sink we got a sink
- dude carrying a grill down our street
wearing a robe hi sky up they're gonna
grill some food yeah I know you guys
don't like when people stop by I'm not
asking for you out with me so I spend up
to like fear and emotion making some
some of my special bourbon bourbon
splash the beans so you guys be alright
if I provide some of it sure let's find
out yeah man seriously I've been working
this recipe from the past week so oh
damn yeah I hope you like it
Spin Master hooked us up with some sweet
Air Hogs drones and what we have here is
the x-wing vs. Death Star battle kit how
this works the Death Star floats on its
own and shoots infrared beams at your
x-wing which you pilot if this hits you
three times this goes down Thank You
Spin Master from sponsoring this where
we are programmed to destroy half of
these in the next hour yeah I got this I
got this I got this is so easy I'm
sitting here just guide me thit I'll
guide you okay
they will take off and I will be timing
them they'll have three attempts on the
Death Star to kill it and once a Death
Star crashes out of the sky they have
officially destroyed the Death Star
judge it based on time whether or not
they destroy the Death Star banter with
their fellow co-pilots and wisdom that
they dispense about the course it's one
of the prizes dignity dignity respect
honor a real lightsaber a real
lightsaber
first up is Nika this is you right here
my son
they're six up
standing by five Danny Boy and some yarn
start
[Music]
yeah I got this I got this I got this is
so easy
I could you just are getting string
right when I hit it I did it I did it
what fourteen point nine six seconds so
Nico had four attempts this round his
first one was false start second on the
Deathstar crashed inadvertently a third
one in fourteen point nine six seconds
he destroyed the star which gives him a
total of 10 points cooking tell him to
move that [ __ ] out of there but no no
seriously he's actually put some BBQ
briquettes on the grill in Israel and
swaggered yeah well I asked him I said
what's going on
he says I'm cooking for Sam and Nico
that's weird you know that I can't stop
you my landlord tells you will be yeah
is this your recipe the Asian theme but
instead of I used some western
ingredients good
all right hungry Jake I guess so
well I'll tell you ordinarily I would
evict immediately any tenant who would
ever I'm serious
barbecue and have that but because it is
Sam and Nico by automatically totally
and fully approval this guy's cool I
approve of him being out here cooking
it's illegal and I love it the more
things that are like that the more this
area stays real and not like those bunch
of [ __ ] that live a few blocks north
up next is going to be Ren one
we got a rope pile in here
[Music]
yeah your footboard
I'm sorry favored the whole time so
Ren's second time was a woman at 17
seconds and 70 some things does it make
it 70 hundredths of a second bad would
you how would you describe that
performance you trained it um it was
probably one of the worst things I've
ever seen
before we go any further I think we
should all go and check out the meet I
have some reservations about the street
meat oh I'm pretty exciting time wait
what is going on meat I heard you guys
yelling about MIDI these Steve's Steve
runs inside saying if there was anyone
else cooking meat but I love salmon Nico
so dude showed up on our street who he
lives
no he's older he's a fan he's openly
acknowledged that he saw the video or
asked will not come by the studio but
you know what he said he would really
like to cook for us
wait are you for real yeah yeah wait he
he did it in any contract anyone no he
said there's ISA for Felicity that's
just like just like it's safe to eat
is it like or is it like poison that
you'll have to find out for yourself
okay [ __ ] who did we draw first to see
who tastes it first I'll try it first
I didn't bring a lunch come and get it
boys mmm
time to meet the chef how's it going
feeling
that's good so basically it's a
gin-based some people don't really know
this one ingredient they never tell you
to put in which you have to put in fish
sauce always you got to put in fish
sauce to have the level of saltiness and
savoriness that you just can't get let's
use whatever liquors you want you can
use bourbon you can use whiskey or you
know you can use vodka
it makes me think like you know like
this is the missile show this is kind of
for real well why is Niko doing so much
better if you've trained everyone here
alright we're gonna up the stakes see
flying in here as exciting as it is
we're gonna up the stakes to really
match the first of the fourth Star Wars
movie we're gonna run the gauntlet all
the way down the hallway you're gonna
have to fly the drone without crashing
it around to the loading dock and then
shoot down the Death Star
[Music]
good job fire the missile son you seen
it
[Music]
some part of the missing son
Sam got shot down an apology Wow thank
you dude you're [ __ ] awesome no you
guys are awesome you guys do seriously
yeah
how's it how's it look Myka looks really
good first ace
ready
it's so good oh hello Todd miss Mao
[Music]
what's up guy yeah you know what I not
gonna lie
[Music]
I'm just like my dear
you
[Music]
imagine this button sweater form are on
sale now in the quarter digital store
quarter digital dot-com slash store
limited time only